meine version sieht so aus mein name ist
luca und ich kann immer noch nicht
richtig zeichnen allerdings finden dass
manche ganz spannend denn ich mal selber
den stift in die hand nehmen und ein
paar leuten photoshop nach zeichen und
da fangen wir jetzt auch schon direkt
mit an das hier ist kran crafter und
dieses bild wurde mir auf twitter
zugesendet und mir wird gesagt luca komm
mach doch mal den kran kraft ein
bisschen schöner
das mache ich dann jetzt auch mal eben
schnell fragt mich bitte nicht wieso max
auf diesem bild in einer tonne sitzt
das kann ich euch selber nicht
beantworten so kriegt er hier noch den
schönen bauch voll mit der schokoladen
farbigen farbe und dann machen wir ihn
jetzt kommt das nächste was wir machen
ist einfach dieser schwimmreifen ihr
mein gott des talents stillleben gemacht
wieso hat er eigentlich einen
schwimmreifen dann auch noch um schön
hier das gesicht die nasenlöcher hier
schön die augenlider dann hier natürlich
die buschigen augenbrauen daran bekommt
er noch welche augenfarbe hat max secude
solche guten lippen okay was haben wir
noch wir haben noch die mauer nicht in
nicht in pink luca nicht in peking
wir machen wir hier die schönen konturen
um seinen arm rom hier hinten und seine
schulter heben die ohren wir zurück um
die ohren wieder zurück und seinen
körper
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir wieder zu viel
mühe gebe oder ob das ist ob ich einfach
guter zeichner bin der auf alle
verteilen wert legen möchte bekommt hier
kommt der markt hat sich doch schon
überall im park geld will nicht einmal
ein bart zu mein gott das auch nicht
schlimm sah ich würde sagen wir ich habe
wieder irgendwas gedrückt deswegen was
kaputt gegangen ist denke wir sind
fertig mit dem bild das heißt wir drehen
hier einfach mal wieder bei dem
ich habe das komplett falsch bezeichnet
merke ich gerade jedoch so können wir
machen also die helligkeit von dem
unteren bild ist jetzt hoch gedreht das
ist das originalbild wenn es euch jetzt
mal anschaut und wippen jetzt rüber auf
das bild was ich gemalt habe von max und
zwar sieht es das tier wurde alter der
sieht ja max sowas von nicht ähnlich was
habe ich für ein monstrum erschaffen ich
sollte eigentlich echt mal immer
unterschriften darunter setzen mit
meinem namen nicht dass das kommunale
irgend jemand klaut und dann sagt sie oh
shit des ordert das ist von leo leoni
das sind mega hässliche unterschriften
hier ich das noch jemand meine arbeit
als seine abstempelt also konkreter
copyright so das ist jetzt ein bild max
das wenn du das siehst es tut mir leid
du bist in echt aber nicht viel hübscher
als dieses mal
das wollte ich nicht so bild ist
natürlich wieder abgespeichert damit ich
dir irgendwie ich weiß nicht mit zu dem
video dance nehmen kann die boarder
keine ahnung schreibt mir mal bitte in
die kommentare
wollt ihr dass sich die irgendwie mit
nehmen und euch schenke und die ersten
die mich darauf ansprechen können dann
so ein bild haben oder oder nicht oder
ich komme es doch an beiden tagen ich
komme doch am siebten und am 8 hier seht
ihr jetzt auch schon das zweite bild was
ich heute mal möchte ich da auch mal
eben die deckkraft rund 50 prozent
es sind zwei youtube rinnen die ich vom
content er jetzt nicht so schaue aber
das bild wird mir sehr auf zugesendet
und mir wurde gesagt luca wir wollen
sehen ob du die hübsch machen kannst das
kann ich denke ich in der tat iran gar
nicht wie viel spaß das macht also ich
bekomme ja auch bei instagram in letzter
zeit immer öfter irgendwelche bilder wo
leute das einfach auch gemacht haben aus
spaß in photoshop weil es einfach witzig
ist nachher dass das den fortschritt so
zu sehen
aber ich hab das echt schon als kind
gemacht ich habe mir so eine kleine
küchen folie genommen die so ein
bisschen durchsichtig war hab' das über
so yu gi oh bildschirm darüber gelegen
hat man diese yukio bilder davon
nachgezeichnet ich weiß nicht weil ich
der einzige das gemacht hat oder habt
ihr so was auch schon mal gemacht
ich denke dass dieses bild nicht mal so
hässlich wird also die beharre bisher
gehend klar die hautfarbe habe ich denke
ich ganz gut getroffen
ich weiß nicht wie das nachher mit
diesen zwei er hat sie wirklich dass in
der nase was ich denke was sie in der
nase hat die schwierigsten sachen die
ich mal musste sind eigentlich fertig
mache jetzt noch mal eben schnell hier
die augen und jetzt gehen wir auch schon
schnurstracks auf die details zu weit
mir wurde gesagt luca wenn du dir so
lange immer mühe gibt dann ist es zwar
auch ganz cool und macht spaß
zuzuschauen
aber es ist witziger wenn du versuchst
schnell zu machen deswegen versuche ich
jetzt mal ein bisschen hier
durchzuziehen und die trotzdem irgendwie
schön hinzukriegen oder die nasen sind
komplett war unglücklich muss sich beide
normal neumann sieht ist nicht so
hässlich aus ich denke mir dann immer so
ja weil man das im hintergrund noch
sieht ja das sieht ja ganz schön aus
oder irgendwie so aber das ist halt
tatsächlich nur der hintergrund
ich selber hab da nur drüber gezeichnet
und es sieht aus wie hin gekürzte
scheiße ich schon zweimal aus ihm heraus
gekommen ist dann wird sie wieder ins
einfach eingesteckt und dann ist sie bei
mir auf der zeichnung so sieht das hier
aus wir neigen uns dem ende zu freunde
und ich würde sogar sagen das ist bisher
das bild ist wo ich mir nicht die meiste
mühe gegeben habe aber wo ich am
längsten dran saß war ich zu viele
sachen irgendwie korrigiert habe und
volver und ich bin jetzt in der raw
datei bei der aufnahme hierbei 24
minuten das heißt ich habe hier
wahrscheinlich gerade irgendwie 12
minuten ran gesetzt und das jetzt dann
irgendwie runter gekürzt oder so aber
ich denke wir sind was hatten die hessen
tattoo das hatten die hier oben für ein
tattoo daran alter der moment der
wahrheit ist gekommen freunde das hier
ist das ursprungs bild und jetzt kommt
meine version von das ist nicht wahr
photoshop denkt sich wieder hier ich bin
ein photoshop meine version von dgb und
paola ist das paola
ich meine ja meine version sieht so aus
was bist du oh mein gott was habe ich
kreiert was ist dass auch ich habe die
spiele von denen von den tabus vergessen
besser als überhaupt spüre ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher
jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich den ganzen
sex expertin nein das heißt ifi news
maximus und das ist das und das trotzdem
hatte ich schon mit eurer mutter her
ursprungs bild mein bild ursprungs bild
schöneres uhrmann
ich muss mir gar nichts machen ich kann
ich mir jetzt noch schön meine
unterschrift hierhin so concur copyright
sodass nicht irgendjemand ankommt und
sagt hey das ist von picasso gemalte
verkauft das für 10 millionen von
crafter dickes geschenk weil zur scheiße
es wird es auch wieder abgespeichert und
wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten bild an alle die sie nicht
kennen das hier ist wie der clever bot
und wenn ihr die clever bordvideos nicht
kennen verlinke ich euch hier mal ein
clever bot video was ihr euch unbedingt
mal anschauen solltet weil da gebe ich
mir sehr viel mühe mit und wie hast mich
jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht ich male
sie einfach mal und das mache ich jetzt
auch ich hasse das ich hatte schon
widerlich die passende deckkraft
ausgewählt ich vollidiot ich war wie das
noch 75er deckkraft und jetzt muss ich
jedes linie nochmal nachziehen obwohl es
die letzten male tatsächlich immer so
war dass wenn ich mit einer blöden
deckkraft angefangen hatte das bild
letztendlich schöner aus erweitern so in
der haut so verschiedene flecken drin
waren
er hört sich jetzt ungesund ansah aber
tatsächlich ganz cool aus tatsächlich
gar nicht mal so schwer zu malen weil
die einfach so perfekt ist also die hat
halt kein wifi direct im klever bewegten
die hat halt keinen riesigen schmuck
jetzt irgendwie um die man
berücksichtigen muss oder irgend ein
komisches tattoo direkt auferstehen
sowie das vorhin hatte ich weiß nicht
ich finde es bisher ganz annehmbar
eigentlich also der sag ich zwar
natürlich bei jedem bild aber ich finde
jetzt hier erkennt man nicht so krass
wie bei max oder so schon direkt am
anfang so luca tut mir leid aber ich
habe heute leider kein bild für dich und
das bild wird extrem scheiße halte ich
doch das ist die hübschesten und die
nicht hingekriegt habe schaut euch das
an der eder sieht sogar so aus als wenn
der mund so ein bisschen offen ist ich
hör auf das nachzumachen
freunde ich glaube wir haben es ich
glaube wir haben schon ich glaube das
war's also das ist das ursprüngliche
bild von ihm so sieht die ursprünglich
aus schön clever bord und so weiter und
so fort dass hier klemmt ursprüngliches
bild mein bild sieht so aus ich find's
schön es ist so fucking heißt es sind
einfach 35 grad raus und ich nehme auf
weil ich vor produzieren muss das haltet
ihr davon
ich finde gar nicht mal so schlimm also
natürlich erwischte ich denke man könnte
erkennen das ist ihr erwarte eine sache
fehlt noch damit man erkennen kann das
ist so jetzt müsse man endlich erkennen
dass damit der clever bord bzw
gemeint ist in bezug auf mich weil sie
hasst mich und das habe ich als cutter
nehmen geschrieben so freundlich wird
sagen das war's hier wieso hab ich grad
wieder geklatscht das war es mit
heutigen folge und kam als youtuber wenn
es euch gefallen hatte ich mich meine
bewertungen freuen wenn ihr sagt ihr
muss wenn ich mal bla bla bla bla bla
zeichnen folgt mir auf twitter und
postet unter dem hashtag x mal was ich
schreiben soll abonniert main kanal
sonst habe ich euch ein ventilator gegen
den linken zeh